Rachel you would that experience you
aren't Broadway but with your husband I
should say Daniel Craig's gonna be sat
right there next week we're just keeping
it warm for ya mouse I can forgive you
actually Rachel because you have come
between me and Daniel I've never met
Daniel but I decided he would be my
husband but why I've actually got one
one of those there's like screen visor
things that you put up at the top let's
say mrs. Daniel Craig wait a minute you
drive a car this down keep it up all the
time you know they sort of ste through
yeah you have the screen visor and I'll
have dialog
[Applause]
but like that we're American audiences
kind of weird about the the two of you
being on stage together because it's
kind of there's part of it's real and
part of its not real cuz you were
playing husband and wife we were we
playing husband and wife in a Pinter
play called betrayal where the husband
is sleeping with his best friend but
yeah I mean I'm Broadway is I've never
done it before it's that way it's it
culturally different to England in that
when a famous person comes onto the
stage even if it's the middle of a sea
you have come in and the second act
there's a huge it's it's it's very it's
very odd I think in Japan people shout
things out is it every country is
something different in England we just
wait to the end we reach to the
Maltesers you just yes not there in
character you have to wait yeah and all
see Daniel gex have really gets a really
big one yeah
[Laughter]
I want to be ridden like a pony
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. Dowd very handsome Matt very ha but
Colin Farrel beautiful right beautiful
man beautiful so hands up everybody here
who's actually been kissed on the lips
by Brad Pitt
[Applause]